A F
TELEO SA, THANK YOU  ON.
>> T YOU FOR HAVINBRU'NISTAN
EXHAUSTED AND SO KINOFE AND YOYS
OVERWHELMED BYG I'VE
OA
WOERTO H BOYS AND  AND
MY PAR
ALSO JUST A SENSE
, ITUST LIKE
COLLAPCA
ND HULETCAN JUST LET
EERS IN MANYLE EXPERIEE  LEAVIN
WEEK IKE.AVE
COUNTRYODEPLA
IS
ITHE'SDIWAELD. BWNOU
ENGINES ON THE AND YOUD ONTO TH
RDIN, AND
THEN ARTAIPOIN
EVERYBSITS DOWN INRE IS ROOM F
TO SITBUT YOU'RE NOT RST GGED,
LE ASKIN WHERE ARE
AT
I T PHONE RK, WHO DO? FIND TH
D E I'M A WENWESTERNER
, RYON QUESTIASF  MIGHTSWS
WHAPPXT THEY'LL
GO ANDT N TO THE
THEN THE ENGINESTA
NESIINTOGETHER, DING
EA OPEED THISER VNG RBU LIKE
OUSAOUD IN DCUTTER.CKD STILL PRR
YOU HA G A TT..
HAO ADMII LAUGHEEAHAHIS
DAERY O GET D .
WHAT WAS THAPRIOLIDOHA
>> IT HAS THE S ARG
THEYBE TINTH
THEY WERORIGIN TAL HUNDRED
THEY 600N THAN
LONCE.
THE SURE THEY HAVE MEDICAHEY NEN
EFRT, A BEENRUGGLINGF ATINTHR OC
A CDINGOOED TTEE THEYO
THE  ON THSIUR THE OF TRYOPLE TE
AND OBSLT'S ER 100, VERYGOE  TOD
AS YOU ST'REMINDER OF, OH,OWD. T
INCREDIBLY
THXPTSUS SO WE WERPLANO HOMES A
OME OF
TE ING OU AND IELHOW GOOD
AN'RT HIM
PLANE, SO THAT TNK.
U K AGO WERE
G  T
CAPITAL FELL TTHTALIBAN.
TKNOWINCO THE
FEAR OTHME
LITERALLY RTPUA GU
IN IUN E UPNG
WHAXPECT. EVERYDASTUSLY
C WE WERE JUST ST OF EATING .R
THENHE VERY  RITY CA LOT OF TALT
ON
TH THERE GOINGNO WE WANCUE? HOUU
E N IN COME
W WHAT
CONVERSATION, AND IN ALL FELWE T
H E
WI TALIBST WEEKS, AND FOR ME, YN
THEIR INTEREST TALLOJOSAFETY.
, M VE WE D.
>> SON TO , AND
DECIDE WHEN T WORSEONSTREET
WE ALL REMR WHEN BRE WAS  A
ED.ACTUALE DECISION
WE WETHINK, WAS MOSTL
AU BEEN IN FTHRERKIN-HOU
EYES  A, KNOW COLLEAGUES --LLE
CREAVER ARE ON THED DOING LE WO.
THE BEAUTOR
ME CATT'A  WL URNS TO MAKE SURE.
>> TO THAT P, I WAS
HOME.ING YOUR BOOIETH
I WAS FLPI PAGESUR EIE
IN AFGHANISTAN IST
YOU WRITE AB TRIP  TALIBANI THIS
S ORED IF OSE TR THE U THIM YO E
HIS INCREDIBLY PO
FOR MYSELF HAVINSP
WI
TERRITOR
EN, HOW E  WAY THAT THEYE MOREP
DOWNPLAY THE DANGER THAT
RAGMATICEYN ASITICALLYTHD  HD
D RTIE
INVOLVED.
SO I THINK G
A LITTE CONFIDCEAGWHT RC
LI WOMHTN THE STS D  ABOUT THIN
>> RIGHT, RIGH
BOIONED -- WE ABOUT EI TODAY.
I HAVE TWO YOU KOU
, WE'VE TALKED
.
HOITURI'M SURE THERE IS A PART
THE DESPERATELY
TO
CHILDREN TO MILITARYS.
HOW DOOUWIT?>> IY THIN
ALLIKEE HARDPA?HAT SCEDIT.
HONESTLYPATHE JO
WHEN I GET TOO TIREDI GET TOWA ,
GO,
LYIS THAJUST B I HAVE LISPORT AE
EA, EVER UT,
CARDBOARD TO THEIR BABIE AR THEU
YOQU